I would not like to be those tires
oh yeah very amusing got the new boss
turn this morning I hear he's a
ballbuster
apparently he is a sheep minnak atrani
wah wah wah
you can look but don't touch we should
sort of ruin her life for a fat best
friend oh you all right
where are my mine England no I'm fine
she's beautiful
mmm Wow my league she's like a 10 I'm a
to like a butterfly garnet with a
parsnip you've got to put yourself out
there he can notice you bruise
what's the pace room this time yeah I
had a nice bud oh come on little I don't
dance
all right make yourself useful she was
at the pub and she was salsa dancing
Oh girls love a man even dance you could
dance in a fiery moneyless Alfie aflame
if you really like this girl I'll sir
your way is back the boy with fires what
do you want from me this one lesson
accomplished
my name is Vijay nice to meet you in
person means hero
what does boost mean a bush or head G
come on we got work to do
legs of a stallion arms of an eagle I
said I need a lot of flippin heron we
met like God use guys like you to get
advice about men like me you don't know
about me I don't know I don't something
about to see that what happens at lunch
stays at lunch
let's settle this like men you need to
dance Bruce got a reach out and grab it
your risk selling haha your biggest live
this is your time Bruce I'm gonna be
late for my ball legs I call you later
I've got something that you don't have
you know wadays
type-2 diabetes